today on the matt walsh show our lords
and masters in the cdc and the white
house have given us new covet guidelines
in their benevolence they are now
allowing us to walk outside and even
have picnics without masks if we're
vaccinated so we'll talk about that also
five headlines including outrage over a
bill in idaho that bans abortion after
the fetal heartbeat is detected and also
outrage over a video of wayne lapierre
nra guy killing an elephant there seems
to be an interesting contrast between
these two stories plus
justin bieber is accused of cultural
appropriation for wearing dreadlocks and
in our daily cancellation will deal with
the claims that there is systemic racism
against black nfl players all of that
and more today on the matt wall show
well you know i had another occasion
over the weekend uh to use
rockauto.com and i've personally been a
loyal rock auto uh customer for
a long time now and i know a lot of my
listeners have been as well because
rockauto.com
is so much easier than walking into a
store uh if you need auto parts and
dealing with with with all of that and
what you're going to find so often is
that they don't have what you need
and you got to they got to go online and
order it anyway you could do that
yourself you have access to rockauto.com
at your desk and in your pocket anytime
rockauto.com you know they're always
going to offer the lowest price possible
so you you know that if you find it at
rockauto.com it's the best price
anywhere you might as well buy it there
rockauto.com is a family business
they've been serving auto parts
customers online for 20 years go to
rockauto.com to shop for auto and body
parts from hundreds of manufacturers
best of all again the prices at
rockauto.com are reliably low they're
the same whether you're professional
do-it-yourselfer
no reason to spend twice as much for the
same parts you got to go to rockauto.com
for an amazing selection and reliably
low prices go to rockauto.com right now
and see all the parts available for your
car or truck and write walsh in there
how did you hear about us box so they
know that we sent you
if we've learned anything over the past
year it's that our lives are not our own
to live we have we have freedom of
course because we're americans but it's
the freedom to do as we're told it's the
freedom to live exactly as we're
instructed to live to go
where we are ordered to go to where what
we are commanded to wear
our masters have been generous with
these freedoms you must admit they've
allowed us for example to stand
six feet away from each other uh they've
allowed us even to be maskless for
several hours each night while sleeping
if we're willing to assume that kind of
risk
they've made many concessions like this
because they are benevolent
and generous
yesterday proving that their generosity
truly knows no bounds both the cdc and
joe biden announced that um some of us
under some circumstances can maybe enjoy
a few more liberties soon
so first the cdc released a new set of
guidelines in the form of a handy chart
with little pictures the pictures are
important
because we are very stupid and we need
our masters to take that into account
when they're telling us what we can and
cannot do so there's little cartoon
pictures of a guy with a mask or not
with a mask according to the chart um
both vaccinated and unvaccinated people
can walk run
or bike outdoors without masks provided
they're only with members of their own
family of course
i am overwhelmed
with gratitude for this although i
personally will choose to remove only
one of my masks while walking outside
the other five will remain in place
because you can never be too careful
indeed i cannot in good conscience
remove all of my masks until the risk of
death has been fully eradicated and
mankind has discovered the elixir of
immortality but that's my own choice and
it's a choice that our masters allow me
to make blessed be their names by the
way joy reid agrees with me she said on
her show yesterday that though she is
fully vaccinated
she still wears two masks while jogging
listen to this
and dr gupta i am among the fully
vaccinated uh joined team pfizer uh and
i did go jogging today in the park uh
and i did this was the mask that i wore
with a doctor's mask under it and most
of the people that i saw that were in
the park the park was packed i would say
like 95 of people still had masks on
there are people who are getting really
upset about that i won't name them
should people be freaking out that some
people like myself who are vaccinated
are still wearing masks outdoors should
we do that
you know you might listen to that and
surmise that joy reid is a demented
paranoid maniacal freak who should be
locked in an insane asylum for her own
good
you might surmise that
you might say that i'm not saying that
but you might say that many people are
saying that as for me i think she's just
exercising reasonable caution again
it cannot be stressed enough there is
still
a risk of death
in general
as humans and some of us are simply not
willing to live our normal lives until
there is no more death of any kind in
the world at all
what's wrong with that
back to the cdc guidelines our masters
also say that both vaccinated and
unvaccinated people are safe to attend
small outdoor family gatherings so you
can for example sit out on your porch
with your own family
you couldn't do that before
now if you did that before you may have
inadvertently killed untold numbers of
innocent people the virus may have
traveled out of your mouth
you know floated on the breeze hitched a
ride on a passing car then walked up to
somebody's house rang the doorbell and
murdered everybody inside this happened
many times
you know the science doesn't lie
but now the science has changed
it is now safe to sit on your porch the
science of porch sitting is quite fluid
we've discovered but but the cdc warns
it is still unsafe to dine outdoors
without a mask
if you're unvaccinated
you must make sure to keep the mask on
while you're eating if you're not
vaccinated now this seems difficult at
first and that's why i've actually
developed the ability to eat with my
ears which is kind of interesting i will
in fact
shove the food into my ears and then
slowly absorb the nutrients that way now
there's still some risk involved here
ear infections can be a major issue i
think i still have last thursday's
mashed potatoes lodged in there
somewhere it also means
i have to take my ear plugs out
providing an opportunity for the virus
to sneak in
but it's still certainly safer than
taking all of my masks off and eating
with my mouth like some kind of heathen
from there the cdc says that of course
if you're going into a crowd of people
even if you're vaccinated
you must wear a mask
is there any evidence that there's any
measurable risk of contracting or
spreading the virus in a crowd if you're
vaccinated
well no but our masters don't need to
provide evidence
asking for evidence is anti-science
it's also quite rude frankly
after all you know let me think about
all they've done for us and here you are
asking for evidence
here you are expecting them to have you
know
reasons for the things they say in the
rules they make
you ungrateful snide little brat
i would spit on you
if the cdc told me it was safe
needless to say
uh the rest of the revised cdc
guidelines make it clear that indoors
everyone must wear a mask vaccinated or
not and nobody is safe indoors if you're
unvaccinated you're not safe indoors or
outdoors
your best bet is to find a way to open
up a portal to another dimension so that
you can reside neither indoors nor
outdoors
nor in any physical place at all
it truly disgusts me you know honestly
that so many unvaccinated people have
not even bothered to open up an internet
dimensional portal at all
yet another basic safety precaution that
these people cannot be bothered to take
now joe biden in response to the new cdc
guidelines gave a speech explaining the
rules in more detail and here's what he
said
earlier today the cdc made an important
announcement
starting today
if you're fully vaccinated
and you're outdoors
you need and not in a big crowd
you no longer need to wear a mask
i want to be absolutely clear
if you're in a crowd like a stadium or
at a conference or a concert
you still need to wear a mask
even if you're outside
but beginning today
gathering with a group of friends
in a park
going for a picnic as long as you are
vaccinated and outdoors you can do it
without a mask
wow
yes the president of the united states
has given us permission
to go for a picnic as long as we're
vaccinated
as for other activities we uh we might
want to engage in he says that maybe
we'll be able to do some of that stuff
after july 4th
next week
i'll be leaning out the path ahead
to continue our fight against coven 19
to get us to july 4th
this our target date to get life in
america closer to normal
and began to celebrate our independence
from the virus
together with our friends and our loved
ones as we celebrate independence day
now you might ask
um
whatever will be safe to do after july
4th why isn't it safe to do that stuff
now what's so special about that date i
know what's special about it
symbolically but what's special about it
scientifically
does the virus know that it's july 4th
is the virus looking to make a grand
poetic exit on july 4th has biden talked
to the virus and learned of this plan
i wouldn't put it past him
but again these are questions
and you should not be asking questions
your job is simply to live every aspect
of your life in accordance with whatever
random rules and policies are put in
place by the bureaucrats and politicians
who rule over us
your job is not to ask questions your
job is not to be skeptical
your job is not to demand accountability
from your leaders all of those things
were fine even good before covid
but coveted changed all of that
how did kova change it
why did kova change it well there you go
again asking more questions
it's like you never learn just do as
you're told
that is how you'll remain alive
until you die of something else which
you will
but don't think about that right now
now let's get to our five headlines
you know we all have our burdens to
carry one burden that i carry is i
encounter in my life a lot of beard envy
you know that's the one thing
it's a risk as a man when you grow a
glorious luscious beard like i have uh
you're gonna there's there are a lot of
envious people out there and but look if
you're envious of my beard and you want
to have a glorious beard of your own
check out beard supply that's what i use
that's what you should be using and we
know we know something about about men
right manly men grow beards they grill
meat and they drink handcrafted booze
those three things those are three
things we all know and thanks to the
manliest giveaway ever some lucky guy
will be able to do all of those things
for free the other thing is real manly
men they figure out a way to do all that
for free because we're also cheap let's
be honest enter to win a stash of goods
from beard supply meet church
desert door howler brothers and more
badass brands for the red-blooded
american male one lucky bearded winner
will get a stash of beard oils and
grooming essentials from beard supply
which you really need if you're gonna go
grow the beard you gotta take care of it
damn it we also get tools for grilling
and leather care and a 200 shopping
spree with outdoor menswear brand howler
brothers you can up your man game with
this stash of goods so enter the beard
supply spring giveaway go to
beardsupply.com
giveaway that's beardsupply.com
giveaway and good luck
so two stories here that might may seem
at first
disconnected but we'll start with this
from the daily wire it says idaho's
republican governor signed a bill into
law on tuesday banning abortions after a
fetal heartbeat can be detected
governor brad little signed the fetal
heartbeat preborn child protection act
which prohibits medical providers from
performing abortion procedures after a
fetal heartbeat can be detected which is
around four to six weeks of pregnancy um
a woman
who received an abortion would be
allowed to sue the medical provider who
performed it
well that's interesting
a woman who receives the abortion can
sue the medical provider who performed
it
i mean i'm i'm fine with with with the
abortionists getting sued don't get me
wrong
but the woman who chose to go through
with that why is she what does she get
to sue
um anyway the only exceptions to the ban
are abortions in case of rape incest or
medical emergencies and a woman seeking
abortion for rape princess must provide
the abortion doctor with a
copy of a police report
little said quote idaho is a state that
values the most innocent of all lives
the lives of babies we should never
relent in our effort to protect the
lives of the preborn now obviously i'm
totally in favor of a law like this i
don't
you know
i don't like the exceptions being put in
place
um
but i'm not i wouldn't oppose the law on
that basis it's certainly a lot better
than not having the law at all
and the reason i don't like the
exception is because
the whole basis
right for
uh putting the law in place is to
protect
the rights
of the unborn human and what we're
saying is it's it's not okay
to kill an
innocent defenseless human being
that actually is the entire case of the
pro-life movement that's it that's all
we're saying
it is never okay to kill an innocent and
defenseless human being
not the same thing as saying it's never
okay to kill a human being there's
situations where you could do that
self-defense being one obviously
but innocent and defenseless you can't
kill an innocent and defenseless human
being
um
and if that is our case which
it is our case as pro-lifers i'm not
sure what other case we could possibly
make
i'm not sure you know if that's not the
basis for
us being opposed to abortion i don't
know what the basis would be
then it doesn't make sense to have
exceptions
for rape and incest um for the for those
the small minority of cases
of abortions that stem for rate from our
opinion incest you're talking about less
than one percent but even in those cases
um
we want to talk about
abortions for rapists
okay you want a death penalty for
rapists i'm all ears we can have that
conversation
but i don't believe in killing the
children of rapists as a penalty
whether they're born or unborn but in
any case
um generally speaking this obviously is
is a is a major step in the right
direction now
uh
pro-abortion people
are not happy about this
needless to say
but then that brings us to the next
story this is from usa today
it says quote
wildlife conservationists are outraged
after a video released by the new yorker
and the trace tuesday shows the head of
the national rifle association and his
wife fatally shooting two endangered
elephants in botswana in 2013. the news
outlet said they obtained a copy of the
video which was originally filed or
rather filmed for an nra sponsored
television series but never aired due to
public relation concerns
in the 10-minute video wayne lapierre jr
executive vice president of the nra can
be seen shooting and wounding a savannah
elephant his guides tracked for him in
botswana's
okemengo delta the video shows lapierre
failing to kill the animal with three
shots at point-blank range
as the animal lies immobile on the
ground and then finally he has to bring
someone else in to kill the animal now
this video went viral is all over the
place on on twitter and social media
um
people very very upset about it
you can go to the youtube video
um
so i think that the new yorker has it on
there on their channel
and you can watch it look at the
comments underneath
it is
people are to put it mildly extremely
upset about this
i can't help but notice
that a lot of the people
upset about a law
stopping quote unquote doctors from
killing unborn humans are the same
people who are upset about killing an
elephant in africa
a lot of the same not all the same
people
now if you are pro-life
and you're also against big game hunting
or any kind of hunting i don't care you
could be pro-life and you're a
vegetarian you don't think we should
kill any animals
i respect that point of view
as long as you understand the hierarchy
here as long as you don't put
people and animals on the same plane
because they're not as long as you
understand that human life is more
important than animal life uh but you
still don't like the idea of killing
animals
i totally
respect that view it's not my view
i personally don't care about hunting
that much i i also don't
it's not what i would choose to do with
my time
if i had a you know two weeks of
vacation i'm not gonna go halfway across
the world to shoot an elephant at
point-blank range i don't i don't under
quite understand
that as a recreational activity
um
but to be honest i don't really care
that much one way or another
and if that's your view as a pro-lifer
fine totally cool
but we know that
a great number of animal rights
activists environmentalists wildlife
conservationists the people that are so
upset about this
many of them are on the left
and so they get this this visceral
reaction of outrage and anger when
someone kills an elephant
but they feel nothing
about human children in the womb human
beings
being ripped apart and discarded
as as waste
just thrown out like they're nothing
so you know there are many differences
between
big game hunting or any kind of hunting
and abortion the number one primary
difference of course is that one is a
human life and one is an animal like an
elephant
um
another another another difference here
is that in abortion
you know the life has no value
whatsoever it's not it's not valued at
all we just we just toss
this um
it was talking about last week
the the the unborn child becomes
to the abortionists and the abortion
becomes medical waste that we was
literally tossed in in a dumpster
or harvested for parts
like an old uh like buick or something
being being harvested for parts that's
that's abortion
and
the people who can see this is what i
could i can never quite
wrap my head around this mentality
where you could look at an
elephant and see enormous or a rhino or
whatever uh big game
you know prey there might be
you could look at an animal like that
and see enormous
value
yet you could look
at a sonogram for exam example and not
see any value at all nothing
it's not even that that you're putting
them on the same
plane it's that with the unborn child
you see no value you see garbage you see
a a cancerous tumor
you see a clump of cells or whatever
phrase you want to use
i ca i cannot understand that
you know in the in the in the unborn
child
that's that's one of the reasons why
you know this excuse that you hear from
pro-abortion people
where they say oh um you know the the
on-board the the or the fetus
is
not a person it's uh you know it's a
it's a potential person
and i always say first of all that's
obviously not true
that's that's a person a person is a
human being
and that is a human being
if it's not a human being then what is
it
what species is it if it's not of the
human species
fetus is not a species fetus is a stage
of development
not the same thing it's like saying oh
that's not a human that's not a person
that's a middle-aged man okay
middle-aged man that's a stage of
development for uh for a human person
fetus quote-unquote is also a stage of
development
but even if i were to agree that
okay it's a quote-unquote potential
person
even which i don't but even then i would
see
this potential person as
a thing of enormous
um incalculable value
i would still see it as more valuable
than an elephant
or at an absolute minimum you would see
it as equal in value
what i don't understand is no value
and that's why i just can't i can't
respect it if you're if you're if your
opposition to hunting comes from your
abundance of love for life in general
that i respect
but for a lot of people it's a
it's not that they value life it's not
even that they value the elephant's life
it's really all about them
right
they see the elephant and to them an
elephant is majestic and beautiful and
and cute or whatever and so that's why
they say you can't kill that but they
don't personally feel anything when they
think about an unborn child and so they
say well you can you you can kill that
it doesn't matter
so really it's all about them in the end
now i can't respect that
all right number two the daily caller
did a little man on the street segment
interviewing uh people in brooklyn
center minneapolis and people in dc
about rioting and looting and how they
they feel about that
and the contrast is really interesting
here so let's um it's kind of the
contrast that maybe you're already
expecting but let's watch it
today we are north of minneapolis in
brooklyn center and we're in washington
dc and asking people what they think of
riots and looting let's see what they
say what do you think about rioting a
lot of the looting that happened in
ferguson just like here
is only caused by opportunities like
change needs to be made and if it's not
getting done in the traditional avenues
then rioting is a good option i
guarantee you nine times out of ten the
people that we're looting are not from
this area if rioting is what gets
people's attention then i think that's
necessary when something like this goes
on the opportunistic people come out
and they try to
i mean i think all violence is bad
violence but in the case when systems
aren't responding to any other forms of
change i can understand people getting
frustrated to the point that they need
to take other avenues we ain't got to be
out here doing the dump the one that is
doing
is the ones that's that's taking it to a
different toe i think that there's a lot
of systematic oppression within the
united states and that looting and
rioting is
very small in comparison to that
so
of course bigotry of low expectations
there uh or or rather bigotry of of no
expectations at all
uh we all know that not a lot of
commentary is needed i did appreciate
the one one girl who says she's just
wrong you couldn't be more wrong in a
single sentence where she says
all violence is bad violence
uh but
looting and writing can be okay that's
completely incomprehensible that's no
part of that is accurate
all violence is bad violence what does
that even mean if you're trying to say
that all violence is bad
well then
then how is rioting okay exactly
all violence is bad without exception
except for the exception of rioting and
looting
that's the exception you make for your
belief that all violence is bad
the exception is
stealing from foot locker and burning it
to the ground on the way out
no no all violence is not bad some
violence is
is morally
uh licit
like self-defense
but
once again we go back to what we're
saying with abortion
when you're when you're committing
violence against innocent people
who didn't do anything to you and are
not presenting any any presenting
themselves as a threat to you in any way
whatsoever
that's a really good indication that it
is bad violence
what looting and rioting is
because it's being done against people
who didn't
totally innocent what the guy the people
the guy who runs the local cvs what the
hell did he do
that's the point
all right number three i wanted to
mention this um i talked about the story
of sam johnson yesterday he was attacked
by the cancel mob based on an out of
context video that supposedly shows him
quote-unquote harassing a guy in a prom
dress but really the video shows the
suppose the supposed harasser is the one
getting harassed in the video
and um and you could go back and watch
that segment from the daily cancellation
yesterday if you didn't see it and we
played the video and everything i'm not
gonna play it again but
i did that segment before the daily wire
published its article on this story with
some more of um sam johnson's own side
of the story
so i want to read this this is from
amanda preston giacomo here at the daily
wire
says nashville resident sam johnson was
fired from his position as ceo of
healthcare company visual on monday his
family was doxed online and he has
received a deluge of threats
but that quote enormous volume of hate
johnson told the daily wire is based on
a false media inflamed narrative
stemming from an out of context viral
video
um
the onslaught was sparked by a video of
johnson that recently went viral online
appearing to show him engaging in
alleged quote homophobia though notably
not once in the video does johnson utter
any homophobic slur or use any profanity
um
the uh
so okay so then it describes the video
we already know about that part
here's johnson talking to the daily wire
and giving a little bit of context
and it's similar to what he told
newsweek but this is what he says
uh johnson says they had been they
speaking of the teens had been at the
hotel slash restaurant for an hour
causing a scene and being loud and
obnoxious i was perturbed that the
management wasn't doing anything to
protect the rest of us who were paying
customers with our kids present
these teens were only there to take
pictures and cause a public scene
there are many lies in the mainstream
articles and interviews including the
allegations of homophobic name calling
and following him
um
johnson said told the daily wire he did
say that stevens looked like an idiot
but said nothing homophobic
and he did look like an idiot by the way
in the prom dress prom dresses which are
made for women not men and so when you
wear a prom dress you're going to look
ridiculous
um and and the thing is almost everyone
will feel that way it's just that very
few will say it out loud
um notably as the video shows johnson
was called names himself himself by the
uh by the two teens he was told to f off
and other expletives and in terms of him
supposedly following the teen here's
what he told the daily wire
the door i was headed towards in the
video led back to the table i was
sitting at with my family
stevens who's the guy in the dress
uh headed in the same direction all of a
sudden which made it appear i was
following him to the uninformed viewer
of their social post which i was not
doing i was simply returning to my
family at the restaurant when they
escalated the conversation with more
foul and vile language and leading
statements about what they thought i
might be thinking trying to get me to
agree to their words
um
and so there you go that's that's that's
his side of the story
and since as far as i know nobody else
and there are a bunch of other people
there when this all happened no one else
has come forward and said anything one
way or another so it's kind of a he said
he said thing
and you could decide who you believe i
personally will say
um
i believe sam johnson on this
his his version of events
makes sense
you know i could see it playing out that
way
you got these two teenagers and by the
way when we say teams i mean they are
teenagers but the guy filming was a
college student and the guy in the dress
is 18 years old so these are actually
grown adult men
um
so you've got the two men there
one's wearing a prom dress
looking for attention
and admits that's why he was wearing it
to break the stigma okay so he's trying
to make a statement he's looking for
attention
um they're being loud obnoxious you know
that that rings true anyone who's been
around 18 and 19 year olds maybe that
might ring true you can imagine them all
in one setting being loud and obnoxious
an adult goes over tries talking to them
and now they say okay now now we've got
we we've reeled in we've sent our bait
out there and we've reeled somebody in
let's get the camera out and um and get
the reaction we're hoping for
and that's where the guy filming it
geitman starts feeding lines to sam
johnson saying oh you think he looks
disgusting you think he looks gross
not because johnson had said that but
because he was suggesting oh here here
are some insults you can say on camera
so that i can put it online and claim
that you're a homophobe
is just so obvious that that's what was
happening
even if we never got this side of the
story from johnson i would i would
assume that based on my own common sense
and the first common sense thing is
again why does a guy wear something like
that to begin with
it's for attention it's to get a
reaction
and he got one
after much effort it seems like he got
one
but what i really wanna you know
of course you're gonna have
the cancel mob
these these mindless drones
they see the video they uh even though
it's clearly out of context it picks up
in the middle of some kind of encounter
there's something before that that
happened but but the mindless drones
online they don't think about that they
don't care uh they assume they have all
the contacts they need and so of course
they're gonna act that way then you have
people like kathy griffin doxing the
family uh well she's she's a scumbag and
so she's gonna act like a scumbag she's
a scumbag who's never contributed
anything of value to society whatsoever
and um so you expect that of her not
that it makes it okay
for me
the the the number one villain in this
story
even more than the the men who are
provoking this on purpose it seems
uh
the number one
villain is visual the company that sam
johnson works for
and they they kick him to the curb
within hours of this video going viral
claiming that they we investigated it
well how much of investigation could you
possibly do
in a few hours
on a sunday or whatever it was
no it's just um
i mean this is
someone who was your ceo i don't know
how long you worked there
but he was working there you hadn't
fired him before for for any reason so
presumably he was doing his job well
kick him right to the curb
you know if you're if if you work at
visual
now this this tells you something
this is how visual values its people
which is not at all
they're not going to stand by you
you're done it's not and it's not just
that they fired him
but they publicly condemned him
threw him to the wolves
this abhorrent behavior we condemn it
it wasn't even as though they they
quietly handled it in a professional
private way
now they threw them right to the wolves
not the only company to do that but
um i i would say if you work for a
company
and you see them respond to a pr crisis
this way
where they their first reaction
is to take their person the guy you know
works for them and throw them under the
bus then uh you know if i worked for
visual or a company like that i'd be
looking for
employment elsewhere
because you could be next
and that tells you they don't value you
they don't care about you
they have no loyalty to you whatsoever
all right number four joe rogan was
trending yesterday with um people
calling for him to be fired and uh
outraged over this from his podcast
let's listen
people say do you think it's safe to get
vaccinated i've said yeah i think for
the most part it's safe to get
vaccinated i do i do
but if you're like 21 years old and you
say to me should i get vaccinated i go
no yeah are you healthy
are you a healthy person like look don't
do anything stupid but you should take
care of yourself you should if you're if
you're a healthy person and you're
exercising all the time and you're young
and you're eating well like i don't
think you need to worry about this yeah
i tend to agree with you but there's a
lot of jobs that will tell you you need
to have this well that's what's starting
to happen people are worried about them
doing it for their children and we
talked about this earlier that that you
might have to have your your children
vaccinated and you know i can tell you
as someone who's both both my children
got the the virus it was nothing
i mean i hate to say that if someone's
children died from this i'm very sorry
that that happened i'm not i'm not in
any way diminishing that but i'm saying
the personal experience that my children
had with covid was nothing
one of the kids had a headache the other
one didn't feel good for a couple days
like maybe i mean not feel good like
like no no big deal no coughing no no no
achy no like in agony there was none of
that it was very mild it was it was akin
to them getting a cold
okay people were really upset about that
nothing he said there was extreme all of
it
perfectly
sensible but even in that
he feels the need to almost apologize
for and add a lot of qualification to
his own experience or his children's own
experience with the virus
you know it reminds me of i saw this
morning on twitter some some guy in
media was apologizing because he
apparently had
a few days prior
got in the vaccine had some side effects
uh you know he's feeling sick and he
tweeted about that
uh and then today he apologized for
tweeting it and telling people his own
experience because he was you know he
realized it was irresponsible and it
might cause people to not get the
vaccine
so we're at a point now where you're
you're not supposed to even talk about
your own experience
if it might encourage people to make
choices that the powers that be don't
want them to make
but everything joe rogan said they're
perfectly sensible um
yeah if you're if you're a healthy 21
year old
get the vaccine if you want
yeah there's
there's no
real pressing medical need for it
and that's it make your own choice
um finally this is from the guardian it
says justin bieber a really important
story here uh has been accused of
cultural appropriation
and uh being a dilettante dipping his
toe in the culture quote unquote after
changing his hairstyle the canadian
singer debuted
his new dreadlock style on sunday on
instagram then posted a close-up on
monday as in 2016 when he was pictured
in cornrows the images prompted outrage
on social media
and i don't have to read all the outrage
reactions but but suffice it to say he
had dreadlocks and uh there are a lot of
people who have opinions about the about
justin bieber's hairstyle
and who even remember
his hairstyle from 2016
and they haven't gotten over that yet
they're traumatized by it and now he's
just adding insult to inju to injury he
he's having here he is with with another
hairstyle that he's not allowed to have
because he's white
now i'll say and i did see the picture
of justin bieber with the dreadlocks
i i really i basically have no opinion
about what hairstyle justin bieber
chooses to have
um
if i was forced to have an opinion i
would say it's it's not my favorite
thing you know the dreadlocks it's not
my favorite look
is it cultural appropriation no
no because cultural appropriation
doesn't exist
you can't you can't appropriate a
culture it's not the kind of thing that
can be stolen from somebody
you're not when you appropriate
something you're taking something away
from someone else and depriving them of
it
but there's not anyone out there as far
as i know
the fact that justin bieber has
dreadlocks right now that that's not
preventing anyone else from having them
is it
and also um dreadlocks you know
black people don't own dreadlocks and
didn't invent them uh dreadlocks have
existed throughout history for
throughout human history in many
different cultures
again not my favorite look in any
culture but uh but anyone is is free to
do what they want with their hair
all right
let's
let's move on to reading the comments
this one says i'm a photographer from
michigan last night i was shooting a
couple for a pregnancy announcement
right i was shooting a couple okay with
the camera hopefully you're shooting
the couple with the pregnancy
announcement you're shooting them with
the camera i assume
dad is a firefighter and mom is a nurse
we had a 20-minute standoff with some
womanly man because
their words not mine because he refused
to walk past us because we weren't
wearing masks outside
both parents couldn't believe how insane
this was
i wish that i
could assume you were exaggerating but i
can imagine exactly this scenario
he was afraid to walk past you
because you weren't wearing masks what
can i say
it sounds like you guys handle this
exactly the correct way
which is it sounds like you refuse to
put the mask on
which is which is which is correct
that's what you need to do
this is totally his problem
completely your problem
if you don't want to be around other
people without a mask on especially
outside that's your problem not ours you
got to deal with that
if that means you have to stay locked in
your home for you know the next couple
years while more and more people go
maskless outside that's it's your choice
your problem i don't care
i'm not going to do a single damn thing
to accommodate your paranoid delusions
and i'm glad that you guys here in this
case didn't
well done um
let's see another comment says my aunt
wears a mask to sleep
i asked her why she said i'm scared of a
virus and this way i feel safer i
i mentioned wearing a mask to sleep
earlier in the show as like a joke
she actually wears a mask to sleep
that's why i've been saying people's
brains are broken
this is that's in
that's insane behavior
and there's no way that could be healthy
to restrict your breathing like that
every night while you're sleeping
oh my lord that that's that's scary
stuff that's actually scary and sad it's
a little funny but it's also scary and
sad
um cecilia says i hold all parents
responsible for this masked insanity i
pulled my kids out of public school the
minute this lunacy was enacted last year
i refused to torture my children at the
behest of an insane society
no no no i don't care what sacrifice one
has to make to keep their kids home do
it it's your it's your kids for goodness
sakes
yeah that's the especially with children
you know you know how do we really make
this end
it's you refuse to comply with it you
refuse to go along with it
especially when your kids are concerned
and another says matt you missed the
critical phrase mr hornick president of
the michigan chapter of the american
academy of pediatrics said quote and as
they get older they obviously are going
to start asking questions this means he
never sees an end to wearing a mask yeah
i did think about that we played the
the news report out of michigan of um
their mask mandate now for two to four
year olds
and the president of the uh michigan
chapter of the of the american academy
of
pediatrics
was talking about
you know how do you get kids to wear a
mask and he did use the phrase he said
uh well you make sure they wear the mask
and as they get older they're gonna have
more questions and you can answer those
questions as they get older
so how many years do you think our kids
are going to spend in these masks
and finally i got a lot of comments like
this
says matt you think the news crew went
out and found the same vhs that was
rented and not returned you sir are
cancelled yeah we talked about the story
of the
woman who um in oklahoma city who was
who got a felony charge years ago
because she didn't return a sabrina the
teenage witch
vhs tape
and they showed footage of a vhs tape
with sabrina the teenage witch written
on it like handwritten and i pointed out
that what kind of rental place sells a
tape with handwriting on it and many
people said well that obviously wasn't
the actual tape
i understand that but you know what
that's fake news
if you're going to show footage of the
tape i want to see the actual tape
all right these are the standards that i
hold are pressed to
make sure you join us tonight for a
special episode of backstage where we'll
finally be watching biden's first
congressional speech live i don't know
why it says finally here like it's
something i've been looking forward to
i've just been i've been waiting for his
first congressional speech
the moment has arrived
thank god
uh we'll also be giving our analysis in
real time biden has kept us waiting uh
for so long for this speech that we all
everywhere i go people are asking me
when's biting me to give that speech i
just i can't wait to watch it um so you
know that we're ready to to watch it and
give our analysis it streams tonight at
8 30 pm eastern 7 30 central on
dailywire.com and on our youtube channel
daily wire
so make sure you're there for that all
right another high energy episode of
candace is also coming to you this
friday this week candace hosts political
commentator and interviewer dave rubin
they'll have a lot to discuss um
including the recall election of
governor gavin newsom in california and
his new opponent caitlyn jenner as we've
talked about on this show be interested
to see what they have to say about it
subscribe now and stream candace live on
fridays at 9 pm eastern 8 pm central
only on daily wire and i get 25 off a
new membership with code candace at
dailywire.com subscribe now let's get to
our daily cancellation
you know if there's one place in modern
america where success is entirely
determined or has been entirely
determined by merit and skill it's in
professional sports of course they're
always going to be controversies about
this or that player getting the starting
job while this or that supposedly better
players on the bench but overall
speaking in broad strokes the the people
playing sports at the highest level are
there because they're simply the best of
the best
and in many cases uh these are not
people who come from privilege and
wealth
you know it doesn't or didn't matter
what your socioeconomic background was
the people playing at the highest level
were there because they were very very
talented and had worked obsessively hard
that's one of the things i always liked
about sports you can watch sports and
see people who are extremely good at
what they do
competing against one another according
to the rules that are the same for
everyone
and may the best man or best team win
it's not a perfect system the rules
certainly aren't perfect and most
definitely aren't enforced in a perfect
way but but still
generally it works and it's fun to watch
and all of this of course means that the
left has to try and ruin it so over on
espn sports commentator max kellerman
yesterday expressed concern
his antenna has been raised he says
about the possibility that the top three
quarterbacks selected in tomorrow's nfl
draft
might all be white guys
that's a big problem to have too many
white guys drafted in a row kellerman
thinks and he's not alone uh but here he
is explaining
well a lot a lot of football people
really like mac jones the more they look
at him um and so like i like you stephen
they all defer to their wisdom but i
will say this i think what what rubs
people the wrong way maybe like you
stephen a i know it's on my radar is
that sometimes quarterbacks rise
sometimes they fall but what i've
noticed in recent years after decades of
artificial barriers but being put in
place for black quarterbacks that
vis-a-vis white quarterbacks black
quarterbacks in the draft tend to fall
pre-draft their evaluations and
sometimes it's right like daniel jones
looks like he's going to be better than
dwayne haskins and sometimes it's wrong
like mitch trubisky is not as good as
deshaun watson or certainly not patrick
mahomes right
but i say watson because he seemed to be
the guy falling and trubisky the guy
rising and mahomes maybe didn't do
either but the point is the correlation
that can be made is that your status
falls vis-a-vis
white quarterbacks and so that's why my
antenna are up when i noticed one two
and three this year white guy white guy
white guy right but that may be correct
yes well you can't blame max kellerman
he has some unfortunate deficiencies
vis-a-vis iq points and now he's worried
that there's racism against black
quarterbacks as i said he's not alone
there's a lengthy article on the website
the undefeated claiming that there is
quote covert racism in the nfl which
makes it so that whiteness is favored
reading from the article it says
in the case of the lead-up to this
week's nfl draft covert forms of racism
and the evaluation process tend to favor
whiteness
make no mistake fields uh one of the
nfl quarterback prospects will be one of
the first five quarterbacks taken in the
draft but the fact that he started the
college season as the consensus number
two quarterback prospect before
inexplicably dropping as low as the
fifth quarterback at times and some mock
drafts behind two white players with
lesser pedigrees is an indictment of the
antiquated system as it pertains to
black quarterbacks
now this idea that the nfl is somehow
systematically systemically racist
against black people extends beyond the
playing field we've heard for years that
there's a racist conspiracy to keep
black people from being head coaches
the league is so concerned about this
that they've adopted a plan to reward
teams with draft picks if they develop
minority coaches who go on to become
head coaches or gm's
it's only a matter of time before
similar incentives are given to teams to
draft black quarterbacks or black
players at other positions
the plan is to take this last bastion of
sanity where merit and skill have
reigned supreme
and completely destroy it by forcing it
to submit to the left's rules of
identity politics
as we've learned
the left cannot allow anything to exist
on its own terms and by its own rules
now certainly if they can invent
systemic racism in professional sports
they can do it anywhere
if they can find the white privilege
phantom
in modern professional sports they can
find it anywhere so consider this
70 percent of nfl players are black
um or rather are are people of color to
use the politically correct phrase black
people only make up
13 of the population so that 13 supplies
nearly three-quarters of the world's
millionaire professional football
players and yet somehow the league is
still racist against that same group
and it gets better focusing specifically
on quarterbacks
the position where white people are
supposedly favored
four of the top five highest paid
quarterbacks in the league are black
four of the top five
and soon it'll be five of the top five
once lamar jackson gets his payday and
has passed his rookie deal
so looking over to the other positions
we find that along with quarterback
the highest paid wide receiver highest
paid offensive guard highest paid
defensive tackle highest paid linebacker
highest paid cornerback and highest paid
safety are all black
and usually the highest paid running
back is black too but every once in a
while you know you get a white guy like
christian mccaffrey who bucks that trend
but generally that's the way that would
go and we could go further
the the most high profile flashiest and
highest paid positions
on the field are quarterback wide
receiver cornerback and probably these
days pass pass rusher so outside
linebacker and defensive end
as established
the highest paid quarterbacks are black
nearly every wide receiver in the league
is black
nearly every cornerback in the league is
black
and pass rusher is a pretty good racial
mix so systemic racism
against black people in the nfl
if this is systemic racism
then what would it need to look like in
order to not be systemic racism
do we need to simply evict every white
person from the league should we make
them all water boys should aaron rodgers
be on the sideline collecting
sweaty towels and gatorade cups
what do the race hustlers need to see
what would make max kellerman's antenna
go back
down the irony is that is that the
people pretending to stand up for
minority athletes and we can hardly call
them minority athletes as they are the
majority in their chosen field but the
people pretending to come to their aid
are actually only cheapening and
degrading their achievements
the more artificial pressure that's put
on teams to elevate black players and
coaches the more that those players and
coaches are robbed of their achievements
by casting the achievement as the result
of a policy
rather than their own skill and hard
work
this is already happening with black
coaches any black man hired as a head
coach
may well have gotten the job because he
was the best man for it
or
it could be because of the enormous
professional and social pressure put on
teams with head coaching vacancies to
hire a minority candidate
it's impossible to know now
affirmative action as always
hurts the people it's trying to hurt so
at least succeeds in that but it also
hurts the people it's trying to help and
it does it all in an effort to solve a
problem
that doesn't exist
and that's why max kellerman at espn
along with all the other race-baiters at
that network which is like all of them
and in sports media um all of them today
are
canceled
and that'll do it for us today
leave it there thanks for watching
thanks for listening have a great day
godspeed
the matte wall show is produced by sean
hampton executive producer jeremy boring
our supervising producers are mathis
glover and robert sterling our technical
director is austin stevens production
manager pavel vadasky the show is edited
by sasha tolmachov our audio is mixed by
mike coromina hair makeup is done by
nika geneva and our production
coordinator is mckenna waters the matt
wall show is a daily wire production
copyright daily wire 20 21. an
improbable republican floats a bid for
president a bunch of states pass
excellent regulation and blm gets caught
with its fingers in the cookie jar check
it out on the michael knoll show